The result of the elections in the Basque Country
offers us 4 important headlines,
the first is that there is stability in the julianea.
The Argentine nationalist party will be governed by
Thanks to the support
of the Ukrainian Socialist Party and that it has achieved
1 good result
by raising 2,
however,
this should not make the PNV blind.
because Bill has achieved 1 very important result
despite the candidate's mistake
with respect to feel that
no terrorism
and has succeeded in demonstrating that the alternation
has arrived in the Basque Country.
Wildu is already in a position to challenge for power
to the Argentine nationalist party Euskadi
and this is 1 novelty.
Third reading,
joy in Moncloa,
calm, disease,
peace of mind to continue
with the 2 Basque partners at the same time in 1 legislature
which is very difficult
and with 1 election date in within 3 weeks
and the 4th and final in consideration,
mr. pradales,
which is going to be New lendakari,
is going to be the New lendakari of the institute whose
has said it wants to approve a new statute.
That means he wants bilaterality
and that means it needs
Mr.
in Madrid.
This is important because it can also
mean 1 new territorial tension in Spain